con el vértice del ángulo en el punto a
vamos a hacer eso lo ponemos aquí haz
que uno de los rayos pase a través del
punto b déjame hacer que pase por el
punto b
ahí está haz que el otro rayo pase a
través de uno de los otros puntos para
hacer un ángulo agudo y nos pone en una
declaración de que el símbolo de arco
cerca del vértice este de acá indica que
el ángulo está siendo medido o sea que
el ángulo que nos interesa es este de
aquí bueno hay que hacer que este rayo
pase por alguno de los otros dos puntos
de modo que nos quede un ángulo agudo es
decir un ángulo menor a 90 grados y
parece ser que este es el punto correcto
si lo hiciéramos de este lado pues nos
marca que es un ángulo recto y no
queremos eso si lo hacemos por acá
observemos que este ángulo es menor a un
ángulo recto tiene medida menor a 90
grados y por lo tanto es el ángulo que
buscamos
este es un ángulo agudo pues su medida
es menor que 90 grados muy bien vamos a
hacer otros de estos
dice forma un ángulo recto usando los
puntos negros elige uno de los puntos
como el vértice y haz que los rayos
pasen por los otros dos puntos bueno
vamos a ver qué sucede si elijo a este
punto como vértice si elijo a este punto
como vértice un rayo debe pasar por este
punto de acá y otro rayo debe pasar por
este punto de acá pero no tenemos que
este ángulo que se forma no es un ángulo
recto y estamos buscando un ángulo recto
entonces fue incorrecto elegir a este
vértice de acá como como el vértice del
ángulo ay a ese punto entonces lo que
vamos a hacer es pues quitar este ángulo
e intentar aproximar a simple vista al
parecer este ángulo es el de 90 grados
el que tiene a éste como vértice
entonces vamos a poner este vértice aquí
vamos a hacer que este rayo pase por
este punto y que este rayo pase por este
punto de acá muy bien y observa que aquí
nos indican que en efecto es un ángulo
recto bueno este es un ángulo recto pues
su medida es igual a 90 grados vamos a
hacer uno más
dice elige uno de los puntos como el
vértice y haz que los rayos pasen por
los otros dos puntos para formar un
ángulo obtuso muy bien misma idea bueno
si lo vemos así aproximadamente este
debe de ser el ángulo obtuso voy a poner
el vértice aquí y hacer que los rayos
pasen por los otros dos puntos ahí
tenemos un ángulo de 90 grados si lo
hacemos más para acá se hace mayor a 90
grados
por aquí entonces este ángulo es obtuso
pues su medida es mayor que 90 grados
excelente